joining me now with reaction to all of
this author of the Russia hoax Fox News
legal analyst Gregg Jarrett along with
Judicial Watch president tom Fitton and
Congressman Mike Turner gentlemen thank
you for joining me this evening you know
this is a extraordinary and Greg I'll
start with you because while all of what
we've experienced has been surprising to
all of us none of us are naive all of us
have experienced and yet all of us
remember Nixon we all know that the
government can be secretive this has
been extraordinary at any level
what is your take now with this new
revelation is this something par for the
course or does this take it as a change
is a turn into someplace quite different
well I you know if the evidence is there
and I would like to see the explanations
for these text messages but if if the
evidence is there I don't know how you
explain these messages it does appear as
though they are trying to plant a mole
within the transition team to spy on the
Trump campaign and we already know as
bill Barr pointed out to great
controversy that the Trump campaign was
being spied on there was electronic
surveillance there was a confidential
informant and now apparently there may
have been a mole so look the president
was correct when you played the comment
a moment ago this was an attempted coup
a silent non-violent coup based on phony
information to drive him from office and
you know Clinton was the financier
Brennan was the instigator clapper was
the leaker and then you had Christopher
steel and Glenn Simpson the facilitators
who created it all with a fabricated
document and Comey and mccabe and struck
and page were driving the engine of this
attempted coup Jordan airy you know Tom
your organization Judicial Watch has
been pushing for years you know like
like a dog just that will not let go and
some of us and as some individuals some
Americans think well this can't be
happening
this is this is crazy talk and yet now
every day there seems to be something
more remarkable with
work that you've done what do you think
we can expect and where would something
like this ultimately go what can you I
mean the American people are resilient
but what do you think we can expect as
we move forward here well the more we
learn the worse it looks in terms of the
spy gate who effort against President
Trump the FBI right now is hiding text
messages of Andrew McCabe Peter struck
and Lisa page from Judicial Watch so
glad Congress is able to get some of
them but there are others that are still
out there and on top of that you you
start off talking about the presidential
campaign
you can't under you have to remember
that the democratic party apparatus was
involved in this the Democratic National
Committee spent money on this effort to
overthrow the president by working with
Russia Intel they were meeting with the
FBI general counsel just shortly before
the election the lawyer for the DNC and
Hillary Clinton Joe Biden was in this
infamous early January 2017 oval office
meeting with Barack Obama and Susan Rice
and James Comey where they all talked
excitedly about OCA just before Comey
was launched by Obama at then alike
president-elect Trump with this
extraordinary we're going to be threw
the dice we're gonna be seeing an effort
to make it seem as though Joe Biden was
dropped in from the planet Mars somehow
and it's never been involved in any of
this but he's he's been involved in a
great deal you know he's an experienced
man so he knows it's been going on my
you know before I think all of us also
when we deal with things like this and
people say oh they mentioned Watergate
but this is exclusively different and
Watergate was a team of people for and
the president involving a reelection
trying to get information on the
opponent and all of that this is an
agency the law enforcement of the
highest law enforcement of the nation
colluding and spying and working to
change an election that was legal and to
usurp a duly elected president that is
something we've never seen before would
you agree Mike what everyone one of the
things that one of the things that I
think that we have that it would be very
concerned about is that fact that you
know here we have our democratic
institutions the
undermined by the intelligence community
our law-enforcement community who are
entrusted with tools that are supposed
to be keeping us safe they're supposed
to be part of what goes to the heart of
our national security and instead
they're using these tools to undermine
that our democratic principles that are
mine a duly elected president what we've
seen now even with Brennan and clapper
and Comey and the things that they've
said on national TV even post leaving
the Obama administration have been you
know they're they're absolutely
opposition to this president and
certainly I think it is evident in the
ways in which we see the abuse of power
of the Department of Justice the FBI and
our intelligence agencies you know thank
you I I do think reg that we finally
have with the Mueller purport done we
finally have a sense that all right this
is serious business and that we can
actually look at it without being afraid
sure and with the seriousness of taking
care of business that it's not really
about Trump it's not even a partisan
issue
this is about what can happen in a power
framework where there's been no
accountability for generations do you
think we're finally at this point that
that we can do this and that we will do
it in looking at it seriously and
completely if I were James Comey Andrew
McCabe Peter struck Brennan clapper I
would be very very worried and not
sleeping very well the Inspector General
has spent a year examining the origins
of the Trump Russia collusion
investigation we normally see government
investigations if any stuff and it never
becomes anything result I think you will
see criminal referrals in the next 60
days from the IG over to the Department
of Justice bill Barr has made it
abundantly clear he is serious about
undertaking a legitimate investigation
because he realizes the evidence appears
to be there that at the FBI in
particular there was a cesspool of
corruption among the upper echelons the
highest levels and this is this is our
chance as the American people to say to
everyone in the political field that
we're serious about taking care of these
issues that there will be
percussions because our infrastructure
and it relies on a legitimacy that the
American people give to it because we
trust them
great job gentlemen say thank you Tom I
appreciate everybody
sorry it's a weird of time here